yeah welcome to this video playing I'll
come from Israel and Bishop before yeah
i got a request to play the F three
names or because i had um yeah
recommended this and in the video
justice repertoire series on d4 and of
course i can i can play this from time
to time I I often forget to play it and
play III which I'm also studying okay so
we got a very classic response to this
which is very well known from them days
off on back to Kappa Blanca and put
Winnick in fact this is the famous game
but winning kappa blanca this line and
this is some very well known to be em
quite risky for black after all kappa
blanca lost this game rather drastically
okay um I'd like to play a form how to
learn how to prepare that there are many
many ways to do that can-can
maybe play it let's play it dub it's a
bit slower this this is against Knight
a5 to my dear supply queen age form
activating the Queen and looking at at
the h7 um porn okay
I didn't even pay any attention to the
point whoops whoops hmm okay mmm Kim
that the point is not the problem the
problem is the coordination of pieces
everything's hanging a bit here okay but
let's get this night towards the king
after all though the convenience is
slightly off side but the Queen attacks
the bishop on d3 which is very important
I'd like to work with threats night xt5
of course and then taking on h 7 which
is in itself is not not deadly it's got
a GF 8 as a square but damn it's still
on something to to look at of course I
didn't want to to sacrifice the porn hmm
ya need to get something going quickly
let's open up the the the G file maybe
look f-22 g2 it's um this position is
not entirely clear of course I just I
just blundered the porn i didn't didn't
pay any attention but it's um it's not
easy for black to play this d 5 is still
a weakness and look F to G 2 s is
something it's not so easy it's so easy
to to defend and here now I don't really
I don't really see em a great setup for
black move like night h7 for instance
attacking the Queen I can if everything
else fails just take and take D 5 D 5 or
some weakness on that h7 I can also take
you 5 immediately of course I don't need
to take but night h7s is weird anyway
yeah it's not so clear what black is
supposed to do here maybe maybe a move
like 97 or specialty form it's at least
an idea yeah this is some quite weird
but it seems that black gum doesn't
happen some excellent move right i don't
i don't see it at least
yeah I hope there's a knob down ok so
I'm disconnecting or anything ok let's
go look after we do not think too long
this looks like a good strengthening of
the position anyway threatening on g7
yeah it's it's rather passive I don't
know but with Luke g2 if you cannot play
easily Queen a fade because f6 then
hangs maybe 97 and something but group
g2 how do you defend yourself let's
really weird yeah White has a very good
compensation it seems it's not quite
deserved or anything but why it has some
serious compensation okay coming to h4
maybe
now I can also just take it and play
with G to win this way this is strong
nature and night to age 54 yeah you
don't really want to take but if it's
just a concrete line how do you define
g7 now coming to a fait des night h5 and
black explodes I think at least walk or
the check first and then night h5 this
may be even stronger
hmm let's check check this briefly what
is so strongest it's always got g69 h5
g6 I have this check I can win the
exchange but it changes to to the lair
I'd f6 King you form maybe you form
efore threatens screwing h6 made almost
made hmm all right but it's not so so
convincing
mmm yeah I don't see a clear-cut win
strangely enough okay maybe this
why didn't I give h4 of course each flow
of course this was idiotic and no i'm
not drawing of course i still have a
good attack so so no question
despite all the stupid moves why on
earth did I play printer I need to go to
h form of course this was really stupid
was just much better check
I'm warning
yeah the time but at least the position
as rather easy to play yeah couldn't
have could have taken it check check
check yeah yeah bad game yeah really I
played some really weird stuff I wanted
to play Queen age for Lord Qin age five
besides the fact yeah that this is
actually winning winning instantly this
is also good but not not as clear I was
yeah come on but I didn't really see the
wind that the computer is giving yeah I
thought that after this he can play g6e
force the key moves I know if all I had
this idea of you for because I need to
get this Bishop involved but I didn't
see that this point I was only yeah
sometimes you this was bad okay okay
again let's do this what I saw I did see
this line and thought okay you can play
this and it's not entirely clear I can
win the exchange on yate but ok it's
just an exchange and it's a pawn he's
got a porn for that but i didn't i
didn't really I didn't see it here and
now is he is really busted Knight f6
Bishop age six and it's completely over
compounds to play Queen g7 now so you
know how how good exposition is if you
need to play Queen g7 yeah it was a
strange game I mean I just blundered the
e3 porn but after g4 yeah the computer
gives why the winning edge already it's
really weird
night f4 and now it wants to play h6 and
this is bad due to g4 yeah I'd really
this was good I played a good game here
up to a point with G form before it's
really important because it's so so
direct he needs to play age six and now
I've got the g file open and exactly
this idea is a problem or King to h1 and
group g1 and he cannot defend anymore
this is plus two according to computer
cool I am quite strange so i blundered a
three but it wasn't really am a big
ischium quite interesting yeah well the
game i played this we're to Queen h5
it's also a winning position here look G
seven wins of course of course hmm yeah
this is the problem but it's this is
difficult to see with a couple of
seconds on the clock this one yeah okay
it's it's just the time scramble thing
yeah thanks for watching